what's up guys bang bang this video is
brought to you by prime xbt
they are a crypto trading platform that
has an excellent award-winning
environment for margin trading if
you want to go check out their crypto
trading
be sure to check out their copy trading
module which allows you to replicate the
trades of the most successful traders
with a proven track record
if you're interested you can register
with the link below and you can get a 50
deposit bonus go check them out at prime
xbt
and let's get into this interview
[Music]
what's going on guys bang bang i've got
roy here thank you so much for doing
this sir
awesome thank you for having me yeah for
sure now i feel weird calling you sir
given that you are in college
but uh that's a good start for us uh
let's just jump into uh your background
uh you wrote this book uh making moon
shots but before we get into the book
just tell us kind of where'd you grow up
and what was the
uh kind of things that you did before
you actually wrote the book
yeah of course awesome so basically grew
up
my i've lived my entire life in in
central jersey um i go
currently go to rutgers i'm studying
finance and astrophysics actually i'm a
sophomore
um but yeah basically you know my
journey into you know
work before before i got to my book and
everything so my dad my entire life he's
worked at bell labs right so you know
sure all the tech people out there know
like how you know innovative and
breakthrough bell labs was in the past
century so that was basically
my childhood right i go to all the labs
right see all the you know
the bronze plaques on you know all the
famous scientists and the nobel prizes
on the inventions i became super
obsessed with that so early on and
um you know it was kind of funny um once
i hit high school i
actually just blocked off all my
curiosity for science and tech and just
felt like the business and sort of the
finance crowd and everything and
um that was basically what i did for
like four years i actually went to a
business administration magnet program
right so for four years right i was
always i was doing all things like
business and you know sort of like
non-technical stuff
um you know right sales operations
marketing you know like you know
focusing on all that stuff and then
um got to college thought i wanted to do
investment banking and
um i was just like i don't know if i
don't know if this is for me right and
actually it's funny because like
recruiting season is like now for for
internships so i'm still determining
like do i go you know full force into
that or not but
nonetheless i i realized like all right
like i might my truest passion starting
at lying you know science tech right
deep tech all that sort of you know
research heavy things and i was like all
right like how do i combine that with
finance and yeah i just thought
you know venture capital especially deep
tech vc was just like the the perfect
sort of combination
and and specifically like if i could be
in this position where i could
not only you know invest and support
into moonshot companies where we're
going to deep tech companies but also
build them so you know incubate them
in-house that would be just like the
coolest job ever i just like you know
why i solve one problem you can solve
multiple ones so
that was basically just like you know
how my journey started my passion
started there so
that was around you know freshman year
first semester and then um
i was like all right i want to do
something bold like i have all this
energy like what do i do with it and
again like i don't know if it was just
the universe looking out for me
serendipity or
luck or fortune but just like i came
across this one um uh one of my mentors
who eventually brought me on the book
writing process so
i just i had i met him on linkedin
actually was kind of funny like i i just
you know struck off a conversation with
him and he was like oh like you know he
he likes to mentor you know typically
professionals not not typically students
but just like
he likes to mentor people and writing
books and everything's just like a
passion of his so
i was like okay like again i have all
this passion out of all this energy like
i know i'm by no means i'm an expert but
like i want to become an expert and he
was just like all right like
you know he took that chance on me and
that yeah i ran with it so
started writing the book exactly one
year ago actually january 2020 um
and and and yes the rest was history it
was just like i sort of it was kind of
funny like i had this like you know
dual mandate right i had to not only
improve my writing craft right
i wanted to be like an actual book right
not just like you know some sort of side
project forever
want to be a really really good book and
also i had to become an expert right so
you know right 12 13 hours a day just
again putting in the research and stuff
you know doing tons and tons of
interviews i had to master that cold
email
you know sort of strategy because you
know i was talking to all these young
big-time vcs and founders and whatnot
and you know here i was a freshman in
college so
it's kind of funny and then um yeah
again yeah the rest is history it just
made the most of like
copenhagen you know being at home and
when i had all the time in the world um
so yeah and then yeah
when you start writing the book uh how
long did it take and kind of what was
the research process
process like to write this book making
moonshots
yeah of course so um the research
process was basically you know
i had to really really improve my
contents and think that was probably the
biggest thing
um you know look where others aren't
right like i had to do a lot of you know
i did like a lot of like profiles onto
you know some of the moonshot companies
out there that you know really sort of
inspire me and
you know sort of have to formulate you
know sell like these this and everything
and then
you know maybe like a solid outline of
like what what actually do i want to you
know
put forth and basically you know my
reasoning behind you know moonshots
whatever is just like you know
these are really like the companies that
actually you know have some solid impact
in the world but not only that but
they're also you know financially
standing where they're they're solid
businesses and
i just think it's just this it's it's
heroic at the end of the day and i just
really i'm
you know inspired by all these sorts of
you know moonshot companies and
um you know i took sort of like a
multi-faceted approach right i didn't
want to
write just you know another boring you
know management book or business book
whatever i really wanted you know
something dynamic so
the way i went about my research um yeah
as i told before right so i focus on
right the psychology right the mindset
of these young moonshot founders right
the philosophies that they
that they sort of you know um that they
that they use and take in my mental
models and so forth and then also your
strategies right how to get sort of
started on this you know moonshot sort
of journey and and also sort of you know
end with like the
the ecosystem right how can we improve
government education startups academia
um
vc and whatnot and and you know sort of
how all they interact and stuff and
so you know i tried to take like a
different sort of approach to you know
companies and and and startups and
whatnot so um you know did deep
deep sort of research into those tons of
deep dives um
a lot of you know i include a lot of
like um you know sort of minor sort of
small case studies of you know as
examples in my book and whatnot so i did
a lot of you know
things for that but then i think the
biggest thing was honestly the
interviews
um tons and i think i did around like
100 or so interviews of you know all the
best
sort of uh vcs and and and and found and
found
i talked to some awesome people and it
was like really cool just like you know
being this outsider honestly again
college freshman right like not not at
that like a target school or whatever
but just like you know
i got you know 30 minutes an hour with
these awesome people and and that was
probably the most sort of
impactful things in terms of research
because got some awesome stories awesome
thoughts and so forth so
yeah who are the people that uh were
like the most
um kind of like oh my god i can't
believe i'm talking to this person in
the book
yeah yeah of course so um i think the
go-to answer will obviously be josh
wolfe um i interviewed him for a book he
ended up hiring me
a couple months after so that was really
cool um just like lux capital on you
know there's like there's like a few vc
firms out there right like you know
lux capital you know social capital hvc
coast like they obviously really top
tier deep tech funds like they're just
so inspiring to me i absolutely love
what they do so
it's really cool like i spoke to a
couple people at those at those various
firms and whatnot and yeah i would say
yeah
the go-to answer is definitely josh wolf
um because you know he's he's high up
there in the deep tech world right
everyone knows him and i was just like
wow like
pretty cool together get a good call
with him so yeah so let's talk a little
bit about the
idea of a moonshot versus like
incremental uh progress of technology
and science
why are moonshots so important
yeah of course so again at the end of
the day um
there's so many aspects i mean the way
the way i sort of consider it is like
all right like
there's so many you know there's so many
you know different random companies out
there right
i you maybe want to call them shallow
tech and normal companies like whatever
you want to call them
that's great and all but like we i feel
like we're sort of lacking in like you
know the people who are actually solving
like
really really big problems in the world
right everything from space to you know
cancer to like the oceans and whatnot
and then you know
rebuilding sort of you know
infrastructure and and whatever may be
right there's poverty homelessness food
scarcity i mean you name it there's so
much out there right
and it's just like i i really just
wanted to you know
create sort of like um you know it's
like one stop shop right really
this piece of literature on like how
anyone can actually you know make make
you know
said you know solve said um problem or
whatever maybe like you know
by means of vs startups and whatnot and
you know it at the end of the day it's
just like
they're so heroic to me right they're
they're they're so like you know like
they
they actually change the course of
humanity and you know put us back on
this like
um you know the disorder you know this
rate of scientific and technological
progress like
i love sort of you know i'm thinking
like uh progress and whatnot as
a as a whole sort of as an ecosystem
right you know as as like as like
humankind and whatnot and
again like these are the companies or
the projects or you know um the
organizations that actually you know
push forth humanity like
and and sort of you know track that
we're on um you know you have everything
from
right the apollo missions right the
original moonshot that's where the term
came
um that kim came about so you know
everything from the other the policy
right so you know you have um all these
your government projects right the era
of big science back in yeah the past
century
but then you have you know nowadays
right literally like you know single um
companies right or you know people like
elon musk but you know there's a lot of
other people
that like like elon that don't have the
media presence but are doing you know
such amazing things so again like it's
just like this
inspiring sort of um you know you know
empowering sort of thing that that
people go on and i just want to you know
create literature on that on how anyone
can can do so so yeah
and when you think through this um i
know there's a part of the book that
basically covers what
government what uh educational
institutions you know kind of the
environment
uh components and the investment side
can do to increase the number of
moonshots walk through like what you
learned there
why are there not more moon shots and
what can we do to increase the amount of
moon shots
yeah of course so yeah i love thinking
about on the ecosystem level so
i mean for example right like in terms
of government um
you know all right so like you know one
of uh one of the sort of aspects of you
know making you know a moonshot moonshot
right so there's
a lot of sort of um interactions between
right the private and public sector
right so you got you know startups you
got academia you got you know
vc funding and you also have the
government um right the original sort of
apollo missions right that's what it was
that right this awesome collaboration
between
you know all things private and all
things public and stuff so you know in
terms of government i mean
i feel like there's a lot of sort of um
systemic sort of reasons why we don't
pursue moonshots right like for
for an example right um politicians for
example right
two years four years and six years right
six years for senators right they're
only thinking in terms of right two four
and six years right
uh representatives presidents and then
and senators and whatnot so
if you think about it like why would
they care about a ten-year sort of you
know
project or or something like really you
know
probably going to fail a risky sort of
you know breakthrough or whatever may be
or you know putting putting you know
funding or attention or whatever maybe
you're a policy around such a
such a topic that probably won't even
happen in sort of you know their sort of
you know
um uh you know that them being you know
the politician that they are and what
not so
again i i just think there's there's so
many sort of uh
ways in which the government's just like
not fundamentally like you know thinking
in the long term
right so that's like one thing really
that's like one thing we could fix also
you know there's things like
um you know special interests and
whatnot i mean like um
in in in in the recent sort of election
one thing uh
one thing i saw you know in regards to
the debates for example the the debate
around you know
sort of oil gas and and things like that
versus clean energy right
again like it's it's what's so
interesting to me is that there's a lot
of you know special interests that are
um you know holding us back in terms of
our energy and whatnot and again it
makes sense right people's like
livelihoods depend on
and on you know oil and gas and whatnot
but then on the other hand right you
have
nuclear energy right you have clean
energy and you know all things like
you know uh climate and whatnot and
fusion even like
there's like so many things that we
could do that are you know much more
cleaner much more sustainable
but at the end of the day like it's it's
so you know heavily politicized right
there it's so complex
and again that that's just another right
oh that's another thing right hyper
politicization and stuff like that i
think fundamentally is
is stopping sort of you know moon shots
from happening and so forth so
you know there's i can go on and on but
nonetheless like what i
realized in terms of government
education whatnot it really comes down
to three things right there's the
you know the these sort of the social
infrastructure social attitude and also
um social incentives right i think if we
could you know focus on those three
things right that that could really
create this
it's really this ecosystem that's really
you know conducive to these you know
big time sort of you know um r d heavy
projects and whatnot so
um so yeah yeah so if that answers your
question
walk me through the anatomy of a moon
shot in the sense of
if you want to be successful with the
moonshot what are the things that need
to go into it
in terms of the team the vision capital
discipline like just walk me through
that yeah absolutely so you know it it
all starts with you know
again it all starts with the team and
everything and sort of you know having
this this this long-term sort of you
know
10-15 year vision about you know what
what what's sort of this preferred
future and
and how can we get to that so um you
know it starts with
this really really you know ambitious
bold you know dreaming big sort of
vision and whatnot and
again again you have to have the right
team and everything but one thing i
found interesting right in regards to
the team
there's a lot of moon shots out there
that are not done by credentialed
experts and i realized like all right
like maybe
you don't you don't need like a phd
right to solve some sort of you know
science heavy project right you don't
need
some you know um formal credentials or
whatever there's
you know even like elon musk but like he
only has like a bachelorette bachelor's
degree in like what like um physics i
think an econ or whatever and
look at him right so again he's just you
know one example the the example i can
think of but
you know that's one thing right so you
know building building like a solid
solid team but not necessarily needing
you know
credentialed experts and whatnot i i
thought that was really interesting and
and how it it it's sort of like the
barriers to actually you know make
such a big sort of impact or a big sort
of company wherever is actually
following so that's really cool
so nonetheless like yeah you have to you
have the team and everything right um
you know once you have the team right
taking advantage of the ecosystem as i
mentioned before right yeah
vc funding what not you know
storytelling's a big thing right um
again the the probably the go-to sort of
story
or example of like you know storytelling
right it's like there are notes for
example right again it was a moonshot
company and it was just like you know
grand sort of vision but at the end they
they i think they're the the way they
sort of you know
tricked you know investors and the
general public is that they over story
told right they were really really good
storytellers and whatnot and
again you you have to sort of you know
attract capital or you have to attract
talent you have to do all these things
and then to do so like you need to be
good storytellers
but you know not not too much to the
point of like you know like there are no
subtle but nonetheless like you have to
be good at that and
and you know everything like that so you
know there there's you know all things
sort of um
you know storytelling right working with
you know the leading edge of all you
know technology remember the cutting
edge of
science and technology right deep tech
is just you know that's the core of what
a moonshot is right
again like as i mentioned before right
there's three things in the moonshine
right there's
a deep text sort of you know advanced
science technology right frontier tech
emerging type
all those synonyms right you got um the
radical solution right so
you know sort of you know something
that's disruptive that's never done
before i'm saying this yeah really
radical
bold ambitious right all these synonyms
and whatnot and then um
you know three and and last right
solving's really big uh problem in the
world
having having an actual sort of you know
global impact and
impacting a million if not a billion of
people so you know in regards to that
that sort of three-part framework
it's sort of again building a company
around those three things and um
you know one right again solving solving
a big problem right once once you get
you know those barriers down once you
you know
hired a hiring right team right with
right right vision and whatnot
all right you know that then you go to
you know the whole commercialization
process so that's a whole other thing
right
again um you know that that's where sort
of academia and startups
sort of you know interact with and then
you know what then you go next stage
right vc funding right so
you know being a solid storyteller and
you know that whole process and then
you know working with like you know the
government for example and you know all
the grants that they give and
as for all the resources that they have
and um yeah
and then it just becomes right like a
you know a typical sort of startup right
typical sort of company and
you know all that all the stuff that
comes with that so um basically you know
in regards like my book i basically say
like all right like i'm gonna tell you
everything that comes
right before actually sort of scaling a
startup right i'm not one to speak on
you know how to
how to run a company right i've never
done that but nonetheless like in
regards to actually getting started on
the process that's sort of you know how
i think about it
what are the areas uh from a moonshot
perspective that you think are really
interesting
like if you were to start a company
today what areas would you look at to
create the next moonshot
oh absolute space space again it's
basically the easiest to go to answer i
absolutely love that um
honestly if i could choose any part of
space though space is space right so
like
what what part of space all right so um
maybe you've heard of it right recently
like varda's face right that one of my
favorite companies ever
um it's just you know sort of you know
lower earth orbit manufacturing wasn't
like that's that's like again that's a
moving challenge right and it's just so
inspiring and
you know i think one thing that's really
that would really be cool
is if is if someone can sort of lay the
infrastructure for
um you know space exploration right sort
of you know um
sort of you know mega scale engineer or
whatever and you know that's
things that go in orbit right that you
know bring us to you know the moon and
mars and you know to
hopefully other planets in the future
right so someone who's like you know
laying that infrastructure for things in
space and and
further exploration there's like some
really cool things right like i've seen
um you know
at my time at lux for example like i've
seen like when companies do like like
orbital transfer vehicles right so you
know the the way to get things actually
to space and yeah from
whatever factories in space or whatever
may be or another company i i've seen
really really cool they're doing like
lunar manufacturing like
that's insane right like how cool is
that right like again that's why i
love moon moonshots it's just like so
like again inspiring it's so like
amazing like like lunar manufacturing
but like
any you would think it's like something
like bold probably impossible thing but
i was talking to the founder and he's
like no he's like serious about it like
there's like actual
like legitimate research around it it's
maybe you know maybe it's going to take
like
15 years or so like it's like i honestly
think it's going to happen so it's like
really really cool so yeah
and anything that's sort of you know
deep space like i absolutely love
looking at all that
so when you think through this uh what
do you want to do with your career like
you wrote the book you're working with
joshua said
josh is fantastic and uh not as a great
track record but he's also a fantastic
human being
um what do you want to do do you want to
build a company do you want to be an
investor
do you want to write more books do you
want are you just crossing your fingers
hoping you graduate college like
what's your goal i mean it's your point
yes absolutely but um
yeah so in terms of you know what i want
to do next so i absolutely love so you
know
i mentioned this before but like i
absolutely love the the model of vc
firms that you know not only invest but
they also build in-house where they
incubate in-house
i absolutely love that i i definitely
want to be in you know maybe maybe i
don't know like a moonshot venture
studio or whatever maybe
just in a position where i could you
know not only you know invest in support
but also build multiple ones like i i
have so many problems like i just want
to solve them all like i don't know i'll
do that somehow
we'll see what happens but you know
there's that but also like you know down
the line like
honestly like like maybe even you're
starting the next bell labs or next you
know xerox park or whatever may be right
all these things that are
sort of rooted in in history and whatnot
like i want to get back to sort of you
know
put us back on track in terms of you
know scientific and technological
progress so
anything to anything to support that
like by all means i'd absolutely love to
do it and
you know i don't know like what that
means you know government right working
in
the education space like even like
entertainment that's like actually one
thing
one thing that's really really cool like
if you think about like you know the so
like some like movies for example really
social network the martian right all
these movies that really inspires like
the general public like
if we could just like make science cool
in some way possible
that's like my life school right so make
science cool right like get everyone's
you know
attention in it and stuff and then yeah
so we'll see how i do that
i'm not too sure at the moment but yeah
i love hey listen
don't uh don't ever count on any dream i
love it um
all right so people can go where to
amazon and they can buy the book making
moonshots they can learn all about
uh kind of the anatomy of a moon shot
and everything from the environment
to uh many many of the conversations you
had with some of the people who are
spending the most time on this um i ask
everyone three questions
uh before i end and then you get to ask
me one question the first is what's the
most important book you ever read you
can't say your own book
so yeah of course of course so there's
one book it's called
it's called letting go um i think it's
by richard dawkins if i'm not mistaken
but um he's like a
psychologist and whatnot and again like
like this book like you know it's all
about
you know letting go like sort of
surrendering in regards like your your
emotions and whatnot and you know
sort of getting through whatever
hardships that you're you know dealing
with and
honestly like like that book was i i i
read that book while i was reading my
book sort of
i'm sorry when i was writing my book um
in terms of like there's so many
tough days right you know blood sweat
and tears i put into this book and a lot
of days you know i'd burn out right a
lot of days i'd sort of you know
just like you know like break down and
have it have like a mental breakdown and
i'd read this book right it's called
letting go
absolutely amazing just like you know
the way he sort of um writes about you
know
anger and and and and you know burnout
and
like you know love and and happiness and
whatever maybe just like all sorts of
emotions and stuff so
i also love that book i'd recommend it
to anyone so yeah that's a great
suggestion
second question is about your sleep
schedule you're in college so i'm
assuming you don't sleep too much
i used to be the same way but one is
that accurate are you not sleeping that
much into
any rituals or anything you do around
sleep yeah so
actually upon viewing some of your your
podcast episodes i
i have been thinking about it more um i
also i see you know like like that one
company like eight sleep or something
like i see a lot of people rave
that's the sponsor man
i told him i told mateo the ceo i said
listen i got to stop asking this
question at some point because everyone
just keeps telling me
i gotta need sleep i already own that i
don't know it's amazing
i'm like this is garbage it's not fun
dates
sleep yeah i don't know like everyone's
ever interested i'm so hyped
like thermal regulation so basically
just yeah it chills the bed
um and so you know as you know if you
sleep in a colder environment you get
better
uh deep sleep uh i mean just wake up
more refreshed so
i hate the fact that mateo is the one
who uh
always is uh sleeping so well because i
feel guilty when i'm around if i haven't
slept
but other than i
no i absolutely i know like yeah some
days are just tough right like like you
know i'm doing full time at lux
full-time student you know was working
on this book last semester so
it was definitely tough to you know get
enough sleep in but um
now i i realized like i you know um that
what's up
uh i was giving that one book um like
why would we sleep or something
everyone yeah matthew walker exactly i'm
just like all right like
i need to focus on this you know
actually like i want to be healthy and
whatnot so
it's starting sort of you know like me
being more intentional around it right
like you know
putting out sugars right before like you
know at a certain time or stop being at
a certain time right the
temperature definitely i've been trying
to do that um not on a thermal regulated
bed but you know
typically like you know ac and heater
and whatnot yeah all these things i'm
slowly getting there yeah
i love it uh last question you get asked
me one aliens if you're so obsessed with
space are aliens real or no you believe
a hundred percent um
i think they've been here already i'm
not even joking so all right so
one thing and actually um i know in your
interview with mike salon right
he he said that you know there's
evidence of you know ufos but he's
neutral on aliens
i think because there are ufos
aliens exist and and what i what i mean
by that so far is so i was actually
talking to one one of my friends he's a
ufo researcher not you know not a
conspiracy theorist like actually like
he worked for you know norad where he
worked for congress and what not in
terms of you know ufo research and
whatnot so he's pretty high up there and
he was talking so like all right so he
told me this one story again um
i'm sure have you you've seen those you
know the those like leaked videos from
like navy for example right yeah yeah
i'm sure a lot of people saw that right
so he was telling me this the story of
that and i was just like wait so
um basically you know how how that that
sort of instance went is that like all
right like they were you know tracking
the sort of you know ufo
flying throughout the air and whatnot
and the it was on like a navy ship or
he was saying and um the person was
running sonar like radar or something i
forgot what
um he noticed that this sort of ufo it
sort of violated all sort of everything
that we know about physics right it was
just
not in line with what we know and you
know it was going from you know like
like mach 31 or mother daily like you
know 31 or however many times you know
this the the speed of you know
sound and whatnot or light or i'm mixing
it up but nonetheless like you know it's
going just crazy speed
it was making all these turns that are
just physically impossible and i'm just
like all right like
great that's great not very it's all
well documented it's not like you know
random sort of you know conspiracy
theories but like all right like
if it's doing that and that's not
humanly possible like what's the other
sort of
you know um sort of um explanation of
that like i
i think i i feel like that's like pretty
clear like obviously there is no
evidence of you know
alien actually you know existing but
nonetheless like it's not human so if
it's not human what else can it be
that's sort of how i think about it so
so yeah maybe it's a new version of a
dinosaur who knows
who knows i'm pretty cool i'm joking i'm
joking i'm joking
all right what questions you got for me
to uh to finish up
yeah yeah of course so actually you know
um i know you know big big crypto guy i
know you like that so one thing i'm
really curious about and you know one
thing i've read about in my book
actually just like the cultural aspect
around you know all this you know
frontier tech right and
and and sort of um emerging tech right
all these sciences and whatever it may
be so
i'm curious like how do we change
culture so that people are more sort of
you know
accepting of bitcoin or crypto for
example or just you know in general just
you know
of of these sort of you know really
emerging sciences and technologies
you don't have to change anything
they're going to be accepting of it
either way
because what ends up happening is that
you're going to get the people who
determine culture will eventually
realize what this is so if you notice
recently
meek mill you know joe budden um a bunch
of other people that i don't know if
they want it publicly known or not that
they're
uh they're participating but like people
in the hip hop culture right athletes
uh celebrities all these people start to
kind of warm up to it and then they say
no they're just like
yeah this is the thing right and when
that happens
um culture just naturally shifts because
they set culture and if they become
interested in something that culture
will follow and so i think that it's
less about like yes i mean sure you
could go like educate them on it or give
them
some or whatever but i just think that
just it's natural just kind of
progression over time
i'm actually a big believer that like
you don't want to short-circuit the
kind of natural adoption of technology
because when you do that you actually
make it
more likely that it will be
unsustainable over a long period so
i think that uh it's um just a natural
thing that's gonna happen it's already
happening and i think it only continues
so we'll see what happens
that's awesome yeah that's awesome yeah
we'll see
where can i send people to find you on
the internet yeah of course so
super super active on twitter um are on
a zero three underscore
um you know linkedin as well um i'm
sorry i started trying to you know start
like a blog and everything around you
know deep tech and moonshots and stuff
so it's all my twitter like i do
everything on twitter now all right so
what was your twitter handle
oh arana zero three underscore r
ron so r r a n a zero three
n zero three and underscore what's the
three four
um i'm the third child so i just like
always have three
it's been like i'm the third my my
grandfather my father
so i was like hey maybe you're a third
too yeah yeah for
for like baseball literally again i
always use three like every sport i
played just like three
it's almost my thing that's awesome all
right man listen thank you so much for
doing this role i think that people are
gonna absolutely love this
and uh i think that you're onto
something with the moonshots man it's uh
it is very obvious that uh you know
going after moonshots are better
than uh kind of the uh just iterative
approach
to uh technology and science innovation
so i appreciate you uh coming on and i
appreciate you writing the book you
should go check it out making moon shots
you can get it on amazon go read go
educate yourself and let this get in the
future
awesome thank you so much for having me